this is a show called louis i don't know
if you know it and okay yeah with louis
ck and there's this thing called bang
bang which people are probably watching
know exactly what i'm talking about it's
this worst possible thing you can do in
terms of meals
which is you go to a restaurant
do a full meal
and then go to another restaurant and do
a full meal and you pet
you
exactly
so they go
mexican italian sushi pizza barbecue
ihop that that one is disgusting this
kind of thing reminds me
of the joy of food
last time we were hanging out we went we
went to see joe do comedy and then we
went to eat russian food yeah and it was
a particularly
fun experience to
go to a russian restaurant i was the
only
person there that didn't speak russian
yeah and eat russian food with you and
um
because i felt walking in they they
trusted you
they didn't trust me yeah the funny
thing about the the people there they
were talking to you in russian and then
they refused to sort of uh switch to
english even though they understood you
speak no russian this is russian house
in austin by the way
uh anyway what by way of question what's
the worst or or the best depending on
your perspective cheat meal let's call
it a pigging out meal but it could be a
cheap meal
uh that you've ever had or you want to
have that's like on the bucket list or
something that's in the past like where
you did the something like a bang bang
which is like you're talking about
multiple thousands of calories
that you just feel horrible about
yourself you still keep eating because
it's delicious
but also
great company
something about the atmosphere is just
right
screw the diet screw all the things you
know just
like you should be doing but just throw
it all out the window i've done that
several times yeah i don't do this
anymore but um the entire time i was a
postdoc so five years and the entire
time i was a pre-tenured professor so
five years so i
basically followed the tim ferriss slow
carb diet which is you know people can
look it up but it worked really well it
was basically
some you know like good animal proteins
you know fish and meat and things like
that low carb slow carbs like low
glycemic stuff is mostly lentils and
beans and things and vegetables no no
dairy no
um anyway but then
in there sorry no no pasta so it wasn't
low carb it was low glycemic carb and i
did that and it worked terrifically well
just for energy levels because i want to
be able to train and work and then one
day a week
you're supposed to go
full cheat day
and so i would do what used to be 12
hours but then it became 24 you know you
start to redefine what the day is um and
i would
and that was when costello was pretty
young and we would do it together so i
would get pizzas and croissants and
donuts and i would just do the full
thing and by the end of the day you
don't want to look at
an item of food you're just repulsed by
food the only modification i made was
the next day i would fast completely
just to avoid the gastric distress of
eating anything
and
so i would do them on sundays and then
mondays i'd fast all day and then by
tuesday i felt pretty good again but
sunday and monday or
you just feel like you're sliding down
the slope of just
blood sugar disaster terrible idea or a
good idea you know at the time i enjoyed
it i love donuts croissants all that
kind of stuff what's interesting is
after stopping that whole protocol now i
just try and eat well
it's really a protocol now i basically i
do a pseudo intermittent fasting i don't
i'm not really strict but i'll start it
eating around 11. eat my first meal
around 11 i usually train in the morning
eat my last bite of food somewhere
around eight or nine and i'm not super
strict i might have some berries or
something late at night three meals two
meals
two two two meals and then maybe a
little bit of snacking on some nuts or
something in the middle ever fast 24
hours never done a long fast except when
i was doing the the chickpeas and then
um
and actually there are a couple
different ways to do cheat days that
were fun like if you were in a new city
you could try all the
restaurants that you wanted yeah and i
think tim and our mutual friend john
romanello did a i think it was like a
cheat day marathon where they did you
know marathons 26.3 miles they went to
26.3 different locations in new york
they put it on a map and i never took it
to that extreme but
wait over how many days one day that was
their choice what
just because they were you know just a
little bit of something at each place
yeah exactly i mean there are things
that guys do in their 30s that you just
shouldn't do in your 40s i can say that
because i'm in my 40s and uh now i just
try and eat well most days and what's
interesting is about 12 to 14 months ago
i completely lost all appetite for
sweets i don't know what happened i
still love savory food so meat and
butter and cheese
and i love vegetables too i love fruit
also but lost all appetite so if you put
a doughnut in front of me or ice cream
or something like i just
it's it's almost aversive to me and i
don't know what happened i don't know
what changed it's probably a scientific
explanation sure it says to do neurons
dementia
[Laughter]
sugar
the uh the desire for that rush maybe is
gone
from your uh from your soul so what was
the most delicious thing is the
croissant doughnuts what what is there a
thing that um there's a place in uh
portland i don't know if it's still open
called little t's bakery and they have
croissants that easily rival the
croissants in paris people make a lot of
the pastry in paris but it's really the
bread in paris that's amazing we lived
there when i was a kid and we did a
sabbatical there and you know there they
do the baguette morning bake and
afternoon bake and there's nothing like
the bread in paris um or the people you
know and
but if you're in the if you're in the
pacific northwest you know you can find
amazing croissants there what do you do
with the croissant what do you do with
the bread butter or is it just i
actually used to i don't eat them
anymore i don't have much of an appetite
for them even though they're not a sweet
food but um i'm always putting butter on
the croissant
butter on the butter croissant no jam i
would never i would never adulterate my
croissant i i have to actually be honest
about this because people talk about
steak and they talk about bread with
butter i feel like butter is cheating i
feel like you're disrespecting the
fundamental food by adding butter
because
butter it's like it's like it's like a
elite
version of ketchup
you're there we diverge because for me
bread is just a vehicle for butter
a cracker is just a vehicle for cheese
oh so that's just the cracker and the
bread is just texture it's just that
people look at you funny if you if you
just eat the butter straight which
occasionally i do i got it but so i put
a little piece of bread underneath it
not because i'm a low carb strictly low
carb but just because otherwise you get
some funny looks
that's like pasta is a vehicle for pasta
sauce
it's interesting but like indian
non-bread you have uh you have the bread
i i've had a lot of soul-searching on
which part of indian is brings me so
much joy is it the bread or is it all
the sauces that come with the bread well
there we diverge again because for for
whatever reason
and no disrespect to anyone but indian
food doesn't appeal to me well you're a
lucky man because the the number of
calories in that food it sneaks like
non-bread i don't know how naan bread is
made but i think it's just soaked in
oil and it just very intensely like the
density of calories is very very high
for me barbecue i would say is probably
the that's good anytime i'm in austin i
start thinking about barbecue i do love
you know i do love me my dad's argentine
i mean i love steak i love meat i mean
argentina chorizo sausage is an
appetizer before you have steak
so it's meat on top of me and it's not
just you know it's not just the men
right you see women sometimes very
petite women eating steaks that are
bigger than their that their skull size
you know slowly they eat very slowly
there and they all eat dessert too which
is interesting and they generally do
this sort of one meal per day and do
that kind of reflexively that's how i
think about it because i often eat one
meal a day especially when i'm traveling
it feels like a cheap meal because it
allows it gives you a bit of more
freedom
to just lose yourself in the quantity of
the food i did the three day fast and i
ate uh chicken breast like literally
chicken breast with nothing else just
grilled and it was the most delicious
piece of meat i've ever eaten and that
uh and that gives you the problem is
when you fast for three days you really
can't pig out you really shouldn't you
because your stomach will shrink in size
already your gut microbiome is almost
completely depleted by fasting a lot of
people think oh cleanses and fasts are
great for the microbiome they quash your
microbiome however when you start eating
again the microbiome comes back better
than it was before your fast for people
who don't know sergey and todd are on
the call they're kind of pulling stuff
up they just pulled up
phelps with the i forget how many
calories he was eating ten thousand you
know what's interesting there's some
some cool physiology around this the
reason he needed to eat so much is not
that he was burning that many calories
in pure movement it's that when you do
exercise in water even if it's warm
water the heat transfer in water is
greater so you burn far more calories
and again here i'm admittedly lifting
that from
knowledge that was passed on to me by
tim ferriss that i didn't so but i
checked it out and it's absolutely true
so if you exercise in water even if it's
not really cold water your caloric needs
go way up which is why you get out of
the pool and you're often really hungry
and for fans of the human lab podcast
and if you're not a fan what what what
are you doing with your life uh
you would probably chuckle at the fact
that uh andrew just cited his sources
even on that statement
because you're so good at i don't know
how your memory works but
the only person whose memory is better
than joe rogan is yours
you